un dio solita stories
oggi andiamo a vedere le attrazioni più
pericolose al mondo mi raccomando
lasciato un bel like se volete vedere
altre cose interessanti o cose
pericolose temi como di 32 tipo col e
iniziamo subito alla fine del video
potrete scrivere qual è la trazione che
vi ha spaventato di più quella che non
avreste mai il coraggio di fare e quella
che invece avreste il coraggio di fare
pronti iniziamo subito allora non
abbiamo questo ponte sospeso in cina e
mi sto sentendo male solo a guardarlo in
pratica fortunatamente sei legato con
una corda anche perché se non sarebbe
veramente troppo pericoloso delli
saltare da un pezzettino di legno
all'altro e non cadere giù è molto
probabile che cadi visto quanto è
pericoloso però sei legato addio per un
segreto anch'io probabilmente lo farei
così
oggi ho visto sentendo male solo a
guardarlo voi riuscireste ecco è caduto
quindi ok vedi sei comunque legato però
non mi fiderei lo stesso non solo me la
farei addosso ma avrei comunque po
perché non lo so magari la corda si
stacca qualcosa del genere
voi avreste il coraggio di attraversare
questo ponte per spaventoso sì o no
allora nessuno abbiamo già visto nel
video in cui vi faccio vedere le
montagne russe più pericolose al mondo
se non avete visto che lo lascia la fine
di questo video così potete andare a
vederlo e potete vedere meglio nel
dettaglio di cosa si tratta prossimo e
scendere da un vulcano
ovviamente non attivo e questo però mi
sembra più divertente sicuramente sei
molto molto in alto lo stesso però non
lo so mi fa molta meno paura questo
anche se potresti insomma romperti
entrambe le gambe anche le braccia e
rotolare giù
però questo mi sembra divertente vi fa
meno paura di quelli in cui non hai
niente sotto i piedi voi cosa ne pensate
receiver t a fare questo siamo un po
riparato in avanti ma sembra un mega si
vola molto più pericoloso però assicura
che si divertono a fare costa di scelta
infinita tra l'altro ua degli allora
prossimo forse la montagna russa però
non l'ho fatto a vedere l'altro video
perché non era appunto nella classifica
delle più pericolose però è una delle
più veloci in europa è praticamente stai
a lato con le gambe a penzoloni così e
penso che queste siano quelle più
paurose
zero ovviamente sei band imbragato però
non penso proprio che io avrei il
coraggio di farla poi avreste il
coraggio parla rossimo oddio qua penso
che si voglia lanciare tipo bensì
jumping da una montagna
vediamo o forse rimane attaccato al cavo
di sopra vediamo
oddio e così sta aprendo il cancello a
sembra di cadere assieme a lui aiuto wow
ma non capisco dove è seduto ma non si
facesse tappa è una sorta di bechi già
un ping però con una sedia o se ma
queste persone stanno facendo il bagno
vicino a una cascata sono proprio visti
proprio al limite certi si spostano poco
foto si fanno trascinare dall acqua
cadono giù quindi decisamente molto
pericoloso di restare super attento
questo tran fa meno paura degli altri
non mi avvicinerei assolutamente al
bordeaux fa paura questo mi fanno più
paura di altro questo il paesaggio
spettacolare prossimo quasi troviamo in
cina è praticamente è stato costruito
una sorta di passaggio o podio il suo
interno valet nelle montagne in
altissimo anche qua hanno messo delle
travi di legno per passare il più ti
attacca in una sorta di piccola
sicurezza perché sei legato con la corda
però comunque pericolosissimo quindi
cammini così se lo faranno altri di
stato vale e voglio un problema con le
altezze fatevi scappare sta e non sono
l'unica spero di non essere l'unica
comunque si fa e questa bellissima ho
passeggiato e mettete montagne
sicuramente il paesaggio e spettacolare
un'esperienza incredibile però devi
anche essere super coraggioso per farlo
ho vinti io e te rimangono comunque
attaccati con la corda quindi anche se
cadono
non cadono giù diciamo però c'è sempre
un po di pericolo che insomma che non
siano ben attaccati eccetera e
sicuramente faremo delle bellissime foto
e allora prossima avventura pericolosa
sarebbero i safari praticamente qua
siamo nello zimbabwe e allora questo che
porta in città
così si sfida all'italia nomi bar
giaguaro con il guinzaglio è un po
strano e un po brutto anche perché non
mi piace che gli animali selvatici
vengano addomesticati questi tipi di
animali selvatici possano appunto fare i
safari e non me lo stesso spaventano un
sacco perché ben 7 un leone salta
addosso
mio padre l'ha fatto è sicuramente più
coraggioso diverse
ma mi ha detto di un'esperienza
incredibile un'esperienza unica comunque
prendono molte precauzioni
ci sono poi andare o delle g poi
comunque coperte
oppure ci sono quelle in cui vai con
l'egitto aperte però insomma c'è sempre
una guida esperta che sa cosa fare però
sì insomma sicuramente una bellissima
esperienza ma bisogna essere molto
creazione thank you immaginate trovarmi
un leone a pochi metri di distanza
allora eccolo qua nuovamente il fonte di
vetro in cina dove persone un po perché
praticamente c'è un effetto che loro
mettono addio o veri vi sono
terrorizzati per questa ragazza non
riesce neanche a camminare mettono un
effetto nel vetro del pavimento in cui
sembra che si stia rompendo quindi che
stai fa cadere giù ed è terribile
veramente per le persone che stanno
abbassando che forse non lo sanno in
anticipo e quindi si spaventano ancora
di più e questa invece on you di
un'altalena sulle montagne ed ecco
nuovamente neanche io non riuscirei a
camminare illustri sarei sicuramente
come la ragazza di prima perché poi vedi
tutto sotto quindi è veramente difficile
theo per fare adesso sto sentendo male
no come riina perché l'ho portata lì
oddio che vedete è molto ampio sotto
quindi vedi benissimo o no no no non
sono tutti i pantaloni oddio qua
l'amico stesso cercando di tirarlo
fumino no sta piangendo tipo sta ridendo
non li capisco li capisco
oddio guardate sotto quanto si vede bene
no poverino perché erano a forzare ad
alzare così rimasta per più piangendo
pesi appunto poi anche sentirsi male poi
anche se venire o poveri veri bocca e mi
sto sentendo male per loro è rimasto
attaccato
oddio poverino oh no io non riuscirei ad
alzarmi in piedi anche perché quella
ringhiera mi sembra troppo bassa ma non
lo so perché oddio anch'io camminare
così no forse avrei paura di cadere giù
dalla limiterà io camminerei come questo
ragazzo attaccata alla roccia voi come
camminare ste anzi strisciando però
attaccate alla roccia ma questa ragazza
ma soprattutto voi riuscireste a farlo
non perché è in costante davanti perché
addio ancora un pezzo così
no questo video si è trasformato in un
prova a non ridere challenge poi non so
perché ma vedendo altre persone nel
ponte mi verrebbe da pensare che il peso
è troppo grande e che quindi andremo a
cadere tutti noi ecco guardate la
visuale tra tutti danno le ciabattine
sicuramente per non sporcare il vetro e
con quelle ciabattini avrei ancora più
paura di scivolare wow incredibile la
vista comunque incredibile artista
sentito male no sun piangere ma c'è
sempre qualcuno che non invertono bombe
di milano
[Musica]
continua un dio è il contesto qual è
l'effetto che sta rompendo il vetro ed è
terribile questo scherzo me verrebbe un
infarto
non so solo forse lo fanno solo solo
ogni tanto hanno questo scherzo ecco io
andrei proprio così qualcuno mi dovrebbe
trascinare almeno guardo il cielo è
rimasta malissimo ma prima che pianto no
ma perché io mi chiedo perché si vanno
stanno benissimo che stanno andando a
questo ponte potrebbero anche risultare
bottino è terribile
fatemi sapere quali mi ha scioccato di
più a me decisamente questo del ponte di
vetro ma anche quello del punto in cui
lui che saltellare però devi la corda li
queste facendo il ponte di vetro non hai
niente e quindi di restare super attento
potevi sapere quali avrete il coraggio
di fare quali non avresti il coraggio di
fare nei commenti la sas e il minuto e
ora vi lascio quale montagne russe più
pericolosi al mondo cliccate fa per
vederle o se volete vedere altri video
applicata in una delle altre tre tappe
di linee e buona visione
ciao